One of the surprising things about network speed is that a
lot of what determines the end to end speed of a
network in practice is not the throughput, how fast you can
push bits through the channel, but the latency, the time it takes
to get a response from the other end. Let's take a
look at where that latency comes from. For each HTTP request, even
after we've gotten the radio to wake up, we have to
do a DNS lookup to figure out what that domain name server
actually means in terms of IP number. We have
to make a socket connection to that site. We
have to actually send the HTTP request and then
we actually get our data back. Each one of
these steps takes time. On an LTE network, each
one of these requests takes between 240 and 500
milliseconds, depending on whether we already have a connection
going or not. On 3G, each request will take 600
milliseconds to 3.5 seconds, that's per every HTTP request.